in today's social studies we are looking
at everything you need to learn from
celebrities social media first a
never-before-seen performance oh no I'm
sorry not first but a never-before-seen
performance new video of Britney Spears
let's get to it first of all Kanye West
okay his Twitter his Twitter moments
keep us all awake and here's the thing
Burger King has weighed in okay Kanye
West tweets McDonald's is my favorite
restaurant
Burger King with the troll move says
explains a lot
hmm take it in Oh our crew guy Roger
just let out an actual audible laugh in
the studio and that is a rare moment to
get Roger to laugh so Burger King you
win on this one mm-hmm
next up something not so funny just
lovely
look at this Selena Gomez's vocal coach
posting a video of her from back in 2014
take a listen
[Music]
Selina working the pipes and Britney
working the moves okay Britney Spears
when does she not serve for us and now
she's serving us shirtless mess yep
that's Britney Spears taking advantage
of the fact that she is doing another
Las Vegas residency she posted that that
audition she's testing out backup
dancers and says quote teaching the new
boys some new moves
uh-huh hashtag Britney domination you
keep dominating Britney get yourself
what you deserve and that is a bunch of
shirtless men
[Music]
[Applause]